la france d'aujourd'hui c'est si une
france avec avec plein de couleurs on se
sent tous français on est heureux de
porter ce maillot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons travaillé travaillé cela a
été leur passion depuis tout petit et
heureusement que ça brille
[Musique]
moi je suis très heureux d'avoir grandi
en france d'avoir la culture française
même si je suis parti très tôt à
l'étranger
[Musique]
en dehors c'est toujours le même
souriant qui est toujours la bonne
humeur
[Musique]
mais que nombre d'entre eux par rapport
à voir ma coupe de cheveux n'en sais
rien comme je dis toujours c'est fait le
terrain qui parle
[Musique]
vous
sinon bing windows in his private life
or la sun life inc double dvd player
étudiants savent te respectons cause du
spectateur
[Musique]
ç'a toujours été un leader il a sans lui
il est il est un peu comme un grand
frère pour nous holtz et le feu
[Musique]
maintenant je connais le goût de la
défaite en finale et c'est vraiment pas
bon très amer on veut vraiment aller la
chercher on va vraiment se concentrer
donnait tout pour ramener cette coupe à
la maison